camera and your project
hi my name is ashley bell and i'm
nominated for the last exorcism
it is absolutely incredible um this is
my first lead role in the film and have
already been nominated i feel like i've
won already i'm i'm so grateful
i think i'm too emotional to do anything
else
so
so yeah i i love being able to transform
and the what was most fun about this
role was to do the research and be able
to physically transform to have that
space to do that
that that was
what i love most about
acting oh i love to research it's i i
love i
i read every single book i could find i
went to extremist churches i physically
prepared and worked out i
i did everything i could possibly do i
love kind of
getting involved in the character that
way if i have the space to do that and i
lucked out i had about a month of time
to prepare so i i was very blessed to
have all that time yeah
oh
i would love to get into something funny
um i i work out a lot through the
groundlings i'm in their their program
and everything and maybe a physical
comedy next to trip and fall over things
i'd love to
my survival job oh goodness
you know i i've lucked out i've always
been able to act i yeah um but uh the
last film i did i was shot in 20 degree
weather and i was in a wet dress for
three weeks so it was brutal but worth
every second of it but but um i i it was
it was it was brutal i felt i felt like
a like
for monday i'm going to relive this
weekend again and again and again
because i'm having so much fun so
yeah
thank you so much thank you